[Music]
why don't we get this party started
yeah we should all right so
listener the pillpot episodes often
are dedicated to uh what we could call
practical philosophy
that connects critical theory to
everyday events
however we're in quarantine that's not
our only area of interest and that's why
i invite chris on here to microdose with
us
for some more speculative philosophy
like ontology
and metaphysics so that's what we're
doing today chris
you have heard on the de las episodes
and the vitalism episode
and he's been rich in retreat to his
heideggerian cabin
in the wilderness of quebec so how was
that for you
my vitalist friend it was awesome
actually i was on a
farm with pigs and ducks and acres of
land and
it was beautiful the pastoral fantasy
it was it was literally looking out we
were by the way we were in um
my sister bought a a 200 year old school
house
that was like made in 1870 or something
and
been refurbished but it has all the old
wood and everything in there so it
really did feel like
totenoburg well if you don't know chris
he is a shalingian scholar a scholar of
shelling and uh
there are not many declarations i make
about philosophical beliefs or
inclinations but this is one i believe
in
and it's one that we've never actually
thought about surprisingly
yeah i'm i'm i'm um kind of surprised
since you know your own dissertation was
deeply influenced by
whitehead and process metaphysics so and
so yeah the title of this
is process metaphysics
and we are going to start with deliz and
then go backwards to the origin
of western philosophy because de luz
is a process metaphysician and even
though we're setting up this binary
between practical
and pure philosophy de luz didn't really
draw that distinction and he didn't
really adhere to it
he writes on metaphysics as much as he
writes on
uh you know capitalism in his works on
bergson nietzsche spinoza and we could
go on
yeah he would he would say that he's a
transcendental empiricist but what
that itself is a paradox to say that
you're a transcendental
empiricist so yes but also de liz was
quite influenced by one of the biggest
process philosophers right
um henry bergson who we all love here on
this channel
and whitehead and because of whitehead i
think for myself i never need to do
metaphysics or ontology again because i
think he solved
he solved it for me um that's that's
great yes
i know i know you're going to hesitate
but this channel is called
or it has in the subtitle critical
theory and philosophy so this is your
philosophy subsection of that and when
we're doing a micro dose that just means
a general introduction to a really broad
topic that we happen to find
interesting so this is your broad
introduction to
process philosophy for which we are
going to make a case
today we're setting the stage we might
do some more in-depth
episodes later uh depending on the
feedback but that's what we're planning
i think that yeah that's i i hope to do
more episodes
but we'll see we'll see so listener
uh let me set up a binary of
philosophers
in your mind there's always problems
with binaries of course because they
create
uh arbitrary distinctions where they
don't necessarily exist and they
oversimplify however
they are very useful to compare and
contrast
especially if it's a a distinction you
haven't heard before
so the distinction we're setting up
today is between
major philosophy and minor philosophy
otherwise
we could call it process metaphysics
versus substance
metaphysics so do you want to explain
that distinction
what would be the the uh paradigmatic
example of a substance philosopher chris
i would probably start off with plato um
plato has um
he is a an ontology of two different
realms right the realm of the forms
the realm of the ideas um and the realm
of
uh actual entities in the world so
like time accidents yes yes yes
and if you take many classes in
philosophy
often they will tell you that plato is
the origin of western philosophy
which is totally wrong and we're going
to make that case
today although whitehead says he
uh whitehead does love play-doh oh it's
not about loving and non-loving it's
about do we want to set
okay why don't we just get to this
distinction if we're talking about
substance
philosophy for you
the world is made up of things so things
are the original
most basic level of reality whether they
are forms
in plato or for aristotle special
substances
uh uzia or something like that
by the way i don't know any greek
pronunciation so this will be a theme
if i'm mispronouncing them i don't know
if anyone knows the pronunciation of
ancient greek but
just just in case they do uzia is the
special substances so for them the basis
of reality is in
things and things that have identities
and
shapes and numbers and they're countable
whereas process metaphysics says
things only exist after they start to
interact
in time so it's their relation to each
other
temporally that causes things to begin
existing
so when we're talking about substance
versus process
metaphysics the question we're really
asking is what comes first
interactions or objects
even if those objects are invisible even
if they are mental objects like concepts
or forms or ideas
that's a that's a really good place to
start um
because process metaphysics if i want to
give a definition here
right is is an ontology based philosophy
that has two kinds of existence actual
entities are
kind of spatio-temporally ex
are understood as extended events or
processes
um and and there's a an ontology of like
two kinds of existences here
um of entities um
events that are you know things and
um and abstract entities or
ideas like what you were just saying a
second ago so yeah if you can think of
the most
permanent object you can think of like
a tree or actually even more than a tree
because philosophers always use trees
as an example if you can think of a
mountain
a mountain seems like the most solid
object you've ever
observed or witnessed phenomenally
but a mountain is actually just a very
slow process of two
you know earth plates beating each other
and pushing each other up and then a
mountain is formed so
the idea behind process metaphysics is
that even at the level of
causation and even at the level of ideas
interaction and process comes first and
time comes
first not space and not objects
that's a good distinction the liz is
beholden to this because the liz
as you said gets his metaphysics as a
mix of spinoza and bergson
and whitehead all of whom we would
classify probably as process
philosophers
right so for for de lewis the the first
thing is that being is dynamic
and that the dynamic nature of being
should be the primary focus of any kind
of
comprehensive philosophy so he wants to
look at these
it um he would call them you know in the
relation between the virtual and the
actual which we've talked about before
he wants to talk about all these these
processes as
relations he wants to talk about the
kind of relational ontology
and like my favorite example that delis
gives is a thunderstorm
a thunderstorm isn't just one event a
thunderstorm is
cool air warm air condensation
tension all swirling together to form
um this event that we call a
thunderstorm yeah so we have one name
for the thing and
having one name for it kind of throws
you off and thinking oh this must be one
thing but if you look at any
thing according to process philosophy
and delays
then it's going to be a million
different interactions
right and the interactions are primary
this thunderstorm is not primary
it's a it's a pattern recognized only
after all of the interactions happen
and he would say the same thing about
you by the way as a person it's not that
you
have like a a soul
that wanders throughout the world and
has all these accidental events happen
to it first of all
you're a bunch of processes and then you
emerge
into something like consciousness or a
sense of self which is very different
from
philosophy like uh descartes for example
which is the most
right everyone likes to bag onto cart
for exactly this reason and we're not
gonna
do that too much today no but this is
but this is a good this idea of the body
is a perfect example
because think of the body as
multiple events multiple organisms
interacting and the
relations the eye for sight the ear
the mouth the heart processes the
breathing
um everything your olfactory senses i
mean there's so many things going on
within the body the bacteria that's in
the intestines
um the lining of the stomach i mean
there are several interrelations that
make up the human animal
and they come to form a sense of self
and he's not denying that but that sense
of self is emergent
it's not primary it's an emergent
property
so your consciousness is not uh
self-identical to your identity it's
emergent
from your body right
um but plato obviously was not the kind
of
thinker who would think in these terms
so we're not even saying that plato's
you know nuts
because for plato it kind of makes sense
to open up your eyes and look around the
world and see
oh everything's changing things
disappear into nothing and then they
come back
seemingly from nothing so it's not
insane to think oh if we just look
behind
all of the appearances what do you call
or what are called accidents
in philosophy if you look behind all the
accidents there's
there must be something maintaining all
of these emergent accidents
right and process
metaphysics is saying no you don't need
something behind it all
the something that you feel might be
behind it all actually comes from just
witnessing
all of these emergences so
as we said deliz gets his metaphysics
from a bunch of sources but we're
instead of going to start with whitehead
and uh
and bergson why don't we start at the
beginning at the very first
process philosopher at least according
to i think it was
i think we can easily say which you know
the just before we step
into the river there's a into the river
yes
um there's a good distinction here that
we're making
between you know substance and relations
like parmenides
who has a kind of monism and then there
is
heraclitus who i would say is the
the first process
metaphysician for heraclitus things are
constantly changing and are always in a
flux
there's a there's a spontaneity of
becoming
always there in in process
um relations are are interrelated
they're overlapping
and we're making the corny joke of
course that heraclitus
i mean his most famous quote is you can
never step in the same river twice
so the question behind that is of course
what do you call a river is a river
a substance or is it a process famously
quoted by the way
in disney's pocahontas which has
no other no philosophical problems
[Laughter]
i was thinking of cryptus thi philai the
nature loves to hide the fact that we
can never capture nature
since nature is always in process nature
is
is concealing itself and revealing
itself and
it's it's always in this constant
constant flux of of moving from one
condition to the other or one process to
the other
but yes yes disney so we're going to the
very roots of the tree here when we're
talking about
metaphysics maybe we should define
metaphysics actually so
uh metaphusis in uh
greek means nature so
aristotle wrote a book called the
physics which is just about
nature and it means more or less what we
consider physics to be
today how does how do you know objects
and bodies
interact in space um and metaphysics
there's a there's actually a long story
going back to this i think it's like
some early christian monk or something
just had to had to name this book
aristotle's book
what's now called the metaphysics he had
to name it something
and it was sitting next to the physics
so he just called it the metaphysics
so the way we use the word meta today is
is erroneously derived from this
etymology where we think meta means
something over top
right like chris or be on or beyond the
physical yeah
when we're playing dnd you're not
allowed to met a game
because that means going outside of the
game or going over top of the game
but meta i'm guilty of i'm guilty of
doing that all the time
but but metta and the greek etymology
just means like next to or around
so the reason he named metaphysics
metaphysics is just because it was the
book that was sitting
around the book on the physics
yes so it's a it's a mistaken
etymology that now means yeah when we're
talking about like
uh i don't know what's another example
of the way we misuse the word
meta metanarrative right
it's a narrative that overarches all of
history and that's an erroneous
attribution to whoever named
aristotle's book the metaphysics anyway
metaphysics
is the study of causality
which is close to ontology which is the
study of what is so we are at the very
root of the tree of knowledge when we're
talking about heraclitus
uh versus something like plato and
aristotle
so in major philosophy versus minor
philosophy plato and aristotle went out
because if you're taking a course on
intro to western philosophy
you always start with plato and if you
read
delizi's canon it's not one that starts
with
plato in fact heidegger said something
like
philosophy was ruined by plato or
philosophy ended
the minute that plato started writing so
we had
everything that was good had been done
before but heraclitus has this
primordial element
like the all the all the pre-socratic
philosophers were trying to find
the primordial element was it air
was it water and heraclitus thought it
was fire
and that's interesting because fire is
always in process fire is not a thing
it's uh a reaction or an interaction
between other things
does does fire really burn the wood when
when you put a
when you put the wood in um the
fireplace like what's going on between
the relations
between the two of them there yeah and
the wood the wood can be said to be an
object but the fire can't really say
be said to be an object it's sort of a
an emergence or a process
yeah no i really like that i like this
this start with
um heraclitus and emergentism
emergentism
sorry um would you say that emergentism
is a
a movement claimed where my the mind
emerges from matter
plastic um well for something to be
emergent
it's only to say that it's it's to admit
that
the thing exists so yeah you can say
that the mind exists and there's no
problem saying that the mind exists
it's just saying that it emerges from a
multivalent layer of processes
underneath it which include
like we already said your body your
brain
the whole evolution of the human race
from like lower organisms so your mind
is emergent from that whole process it
doesn't exist on its own which is very
different from something like what
the cart or even kant
said that your mind is is
basically something that has fixed
vectors
by which it can interact with the world
yeah i was just about to um
say as a side note here that
when it comes to process metaphysics
we're making a distinction that's not in
the school of rationalism
or empiricism so we kind of have a kind
of realism going on here
or a philosophy of things that
emerge outside of in the kantian terms
the categories or faculties not to get
all jargony with philosophy here
well to get jargony for one second why
don't you explain
chris the delusion concept of university
because that's really important here
okay so university i'll just give you
the etymology breakdown
university means one voice
or one one utterance and what does that
mean for the liz
so weak de les gets this concept of um
the university of being from don scotus
the
famous um uh scholastic
philosopher but really um
university is talking about how
everything is related imminently
in one kind of nice little process at
the end of um
a difference of repetition he talks
about
um 1 million or 1 000
vibrations this is a good example an
echo or a vibration
an echo is just a simple sound however
as the sound picks up and is is it picks
its momentum
it becomes more than just a sound it's
now a co it's now
moving or even ripples in a water right
they make more ripples and more ripples
okay you're out in space i can do this
more simply and if you want to follow
all of those terms they're all correct
they're intellis
um and he's prone to not using terms
that are familiar to us
but university just means that
everything is made
out of the same stuff it is there's not
multiple
layers to reality whereas if you think
of someone like
plato's the one that we're just dunking
on all day
here but plato says no there's there's
what appears to be reality appearances
and then there's real reality and real
reality is behind appearances
whereas what we see is just fake
reality so as soon as you dig make that
move philosophically
you're saying that there's multiple
levels of reality
which is a duo vasity a dual vocity
but a university says no everything is
the same
stuff there's no such thing as
representation
because even to make a representation
you have to use the same stuff
that the thing you're trying to
represent is made out of so
your example of rip ripples in water
which is imminent
to itself there's not anything besides
the water there's not water and air
there's just the water
and the movement the the the
vibrations that occur in the water is
all there is which is to say that
everything is imminent to itself
which is a univocal relationship of
reality
you said that much more elegantly than
me you can tell that i'm very rusty at
the podcast
thing no no no you you know all the
terms it's about
making the terms simplified
so we are simplifying and that's the
whole purpose of this
microdose all right so if you want to
categorize a whole bunch of philosophers
people who would have this dual dual
vocity or a multi
multi-layered reality we would say start
with plato
we have aristotle most of the christian
medieval philosophers
including thomas aquinas um and up until
kant for sure and then after kant
we have logical positivists and so on
who believe that like
if you believe in math and logic more or
less
you believe that there's some
representation to
what we call the objects of bath and
logic which are
things or substances and the
minor tradition here starts with like
heraclitus
we have leibniz who said that the
present is always
pregnant with the future which is sort
of a temporal
emergence bergson as we mentioned
cs purse
hegel maybe would you say hegel is a is
a
process metaphysician well
okay so hegel's a special case because
of
one important uh thinker that has
um imparted great influence on whitehead
and that's fh bradley who is a
you know was the british hegelian and
bradley's text
appearance and reality uh is is you know
it's
the text that whitehead picks up and
he's read and what he's concerned about
is this exact this exact um problem of
substance
versus um relations relational
philosophies and so it's here where
bradley is more focused on the
appearances
and how appearances and their relational
events happen within how we see them
how they are unfolded um
whitehead takes this a little bit and
moves further
so let's just say the hegelianism
of bradley could be seen as process
philosophy i'm not sure
about hegel because well hegel says the
truth emerges through
history but also that there's this
absolute to which all of history is
relative to
so the history part seems like something
processional
and then the absolute part seems like
something substantial
and i don't actually know enough about
hegel to comment on whether that's
whether that absolute is emergent or not
but you know who i would say
all right you know what i would say yeah
and i'm just gonna do it because
he's he's my boy i gotta do this um i
would
because of um someone like matthew t
siegel
uh i've started to see like shelling as
a process philosopher so like
shelling's philosophy of nature he
starts off with
this idea of the unconditioned which is
kind of like a university
where there is an ultimate productivity
that is always producing
and when it stops or when it when it
interacts
with what what he calls actins
um relations are formed and out of those
relations become products so we have
the producing the productivity and then
we have products so
you can see something like this as a
kind of process metaphysics
and and probably nietzsche is a uh is a
process metaphysician in
saying there is no being there's only
becoming there is no
there's no guiding principle in history
there's no universal subject the
universal subject
emerges from the genealogy right
a genealogy of knowledge well now we're
getting a little controversial here
because
i'm not sure if nietzsche is a
volunteerist in regards to like the
philosophy of will
or but yes but in the delusion reading
of nietzsche yes
nietzsche for sure is definitely up
there
in with process metaphysics especially
with the eternal return
and just because we might be losing
people here why don't we
frame this how would this change
your thinking about
events in the world if you were a
process philosopher
versus a substance philosopher because
we already gave the example
i mean i think the best example is
probably are you a thing
are you a thinking thing or are you an
emergent
identity that comes from your body so
that's the
i think the most important way to
consider this
but if you're thinking about other
events uh even
even world events how would substance
versus process division change your mind
and thinking about that
chris well the the first thing is that
substance philosophies tend to see the
world
or filled with filled with furniture
filled with objects they're just objects
out there
um they don't see the the kind of living
this is where my kind of vitalist
tension comes in here they don't see the
interconnection
the relations between specific things um
they simply see things in compartments
they categorize things as simple objects
that are separated from other objects
that are
either there to be used or or
to be interacted with right so if you
want to have like a galaxy brain
where everything is one everything's
connected there's no division between
your ego and the universe
you want to be a process philosopher
absolutely but you know it's as as funny
as this sounds and almost like it's it's
occulty i guess in a weird way there is
this kind of
everything is interconnected and i don't
want to say this i don't want to sound
like i'm
getting all weird on everybody or or you
know
let's go hug a tree or something um
but the whole idea is that
each thing in the world is an act
each thing in the world is an actor that
is
connected within everything else there
there are processes and changes and
becomings happening
all the time and they cannot be isolated
as
this tree is this substance no this tree
is a part of
a greater forest or a part of this or
everything is a part of as you said
you know a ripple within the pond of
several other ripples that are
interacting overlapping and
conditionally moving forward there's a
continuity of movement
this is the whole idea and even in
bergson this this is this
this idea of movement that is the key
aspect of of life uh the progression of
life
and no matter how small the act is
the thought behind university is that it
affects
every other thing in the universe even
if there's no measurable effect right
if there's an event that happens it
affects everything else
and whitehead was not being occulty
when he when he framed his process
metaphysics like this
he was looking at the results of um
quantum
field theory in the 30s
and well was he actually i i think i
always assumed that he was but i never
actually looked up his biographical
details to make sure that you know he he
he actually
he was the only philosopher at the time
that was deeply interested by einstein's
um physics well einstein einstein wasn't
on board with quantum field theory
at the beginning i don't know if he ever
was actually no no okay i just meant
that they
that he he had a a level of grasp
on on physics presumably whitehead was
looking at he already had these things
uh bouncing around in his brain
before this but presumably he was
looking at some of the results
from quantum field theory and the
interaction
by the way i'm not a physicist i i know
enough of the vocabulary of quantum
physics
to be able to relate what white had said
about it but
by no means am i an expert but
the interaction between particles
that are both dually waves and particles
it's not like
being a particle is primary and
being a wave function is secondary
the collapse happens when those two
things interact which is why
uh like a double slit experiment
determines the outcome by what you're
causing to interact in that experiment
so this is why so this is why it's so
hard for us to understand
when we when we move from substance
philosophy into process philosophy
something like the superposition that
you're you're talking about entanglement
well i'm not talking about entanglement
here oh
christ it's only it's only to say that
the
the process of measuring a particle
generates that particle as a particle
rather than as
being a wave function so
what whitehead calls feelings for him
the world
is made out of occasions so occasions of
course is a temporal
word it's a word about time occasions is
a meeting
and a meeting happens when things feel
each other
and white had never ever put this into
terms of atoms
and and uh you know subatomic particles
but he but for him the emergence of
consciousness which he wrote a lot about
in terms of the superject comes from
these
interactions it doesn't come from things
bouncing into each other and that's the
main difference again between substance
metaphysics and process metaphysics
is it's the bounce between two
you know billiard balls to use a
galilean example
it's the bounce between the exam between
the
objects that creates reality it's not
the
objects on their own so this is where
this comes into
saying this is just about what happens
in time
right um and there's more going on
between the the bounce between those two
billiard balls right there's
there there is the inertia there's the
as they hit each other they're moving in
directions they're now
affected by their um by the causal act
between the two of them
right so it's much more than objects
interacting it's
all of these emergent properties that
all come to play in the interaction
and that interaction is what's crucial
here
and this is why we have a univocal world
instead of
a world of representation
why don't we jump back to bergson
because
bergson has a theory of time and he i
think he actually rejected
since we're speaking about the
interaction of science and philosophy
didn't berkson like reject einstein or
something like that so
to this day einstein's um
nobel prize is i think for
um something to do with plunk it has
nothing to do with um
his it's about sub-atomic particles not
about relativity right
right right exactly yes um and this is
because bergson
was debating him on time and he said
that time
isn't just time cannot be relative
time is metaphysical for him and this is
why i wanted to bring up this idea of
realism idealism and the problem between
the two of them
because for bergson there is something
metaphysical that's going on within the
movement of time
and memory at the same same as well
that memory and time
are like a layer of reality that is
a constant homogeneous process so we're
not
separating like if you were a
rationalist you would separate
your memory from reality and say like
that memory is not real that memory is
like a phantasm or something like that
but for bergson
your memory is extremely part and
partial to your movement of your body
throughout the world
so i think i'm glad you brought that up
because that's a good example of
how this univocal relationship is
expressed
you're not it's not like your memory is
false your memory is created out of an
interaction
right actually he gave it um berkshire
has this great example in matter of
memory of
of alzheimer's patients now all of them
are patients
um they forget who they are and their
memories
they forget who they are but they still
have
they still have the the relational in
the relational experience right they
still have this layer
they're they can still write their names
they can still write specific things
and there's yeah there's this great
story about like uh
oh man i'm gonna i'm gonna butcher it
probably but it's the story about
a patient who had like it was like
memento he's got like a
a five minute memory or whatever and
then he was talking about his father
or something and he had already had this
condition once his father had died
but he in speaking said
or referred to his father in the past
tense like he was a good man or
something like that
so even though he had this memory
condition where he couldn't form
memories
somewhere in his body which is like your
your memories inextricably entangled
with your body
he knew that his father had died
even though that he had even though he
couldn't form new memories
that's a great that's a great example
and so this is
this is what bergson was was alluding to
that time um as process is a primordial
entity i don't want to say entity it's a
primordial
conception of being it's not just
it's not just you know uh one train is
moving faster than the other train and
you can see
the light or you can't see the light or
something um
that was a terrible no that's nice the
einstein relativity
theory based on the position of the
observer yeah i get to
i get what you're saying look at look it
up anyway
um so we're talking about time as like
always
evolving around us as opposed to the
western philosophical notion that your
mind
is distinct from time or separate from
time
or that it represents time to you
in this model in process metaphysics
time is much more inextricable
inextricably linked
to your engagement with every
part of the world and even the way that
like we could we could expand this even
further to something like systems theory
where societies evolve
in time not because of you know
atomistic
human individuals but because of the
actions that take place
between those human individuals so this
is very much
a way of saying that everything is
interconnected and every
event has repercussions that are
almost inobservable and i think the
reason that i'm partial to this view
and maybe you can answer this for
yourself but the reason i'm partial to
this view
is because it shows that the distinction
between
representation and reality that's the
thing that's in our heads
that's the thing that we made up because
we're so used to identifying patterns
and once we're identifying patterns then
it looks
for sure like the world is made out of
entities and substances and things
but i think it seems to be much more
true
to form that the world is made out of
emergent
processes and that's why we're voting
for this
process philosophy or what whitehead
calls organic philosophy
no i i like i like this idea of organic
philosophy i i like this idea of
because it you can take it through so
many different levels you can take it to
our last one of our other podcasts that
we talked about with vitalism
um you could talk about it in regards to
um deep ecology um
lots several things it's we're no longer
compartmentalizing
specific entities we're no longer
talking about
this and individuating it it's
individuation
is that it's it's in process but also
different
from other entities but still
always in relation to them so rather
than
plato being confused about how
you know things can emerge things can
die then other things are born so he
says there must be some like backdrop
behind this there must be forms that are
behind all this
then instead you say no everything is
different from every other
thing so there aren't real categories
the categories
is what you bring phenomenally to the
world
but on its own the world is pure process
pure becoming this is really good
example in
in deluse's book on um leibniz on the
fold
and his idea is you think of a sheet of
paper
this sheet of paper can be folded into
any any shape it has the possibility to
be
folded unfolded in endless possible
space
endless possible shapes however
as you bend and fold the paper
there are other relate other relations
are formed
other aspects of the of the sheet of
paper is now touching other aspects
um this is an a this is also an aspect
of
a process philosophy yeah we might like
the butterfly effect as an example
and there's one more way for our our
listeners to to kind of
form a mental picture of this we're very
used to thinking of
ideas as art or photographs right
as visual phenomena as representations
in visual form so like a memory is
is a is a mental picture and throughout
western philosophy
like plato even started talking about
you know paintings of tables are not
tables and tables or representations of
invisible tables that have never existed
perfect tables or whatever
but the other example and this is where
i think deluse bounces off nietzsche a
lot
is instead of talking about visual
phenomena
which seem to be substances right they
have outlines
they're coherent there's a boundary
between them and the world but instead
of thinking about that think about music
and think about how rhythm affects your
body
and how music is a process music well i
mean now we can record it of course
but before we could record music it's a
completely temporal
event so if we have our model of reality
as something that
is is based on something like music and
waves of sound through space rather than
individuated identified
boundaried images then i think we might
have a
richer picture of the interconnectivity
of the world and this sounds like
something i don't know it's
i would call it bergsonian you know
buddhism
or something like that this just oh bro
everything's interconnected everything's
touching each other but that's really
what's at stake in this philosophy
versus the philosophy
of vision or a philosophy of identity
but think about this for a second this
is a really good example
everyone has that one song that always
stays
in their head so think about the time
you're driving in your car
you hear this song um it's on the radio
you're like ugh
i'm stuck in traffic you're hearing the
song but when you go home
that song is just as vivid and it's
playing in your head and you're still
affected
it still affects your mood you you could
it could
you could sing it you could get
goosebumps from it you could get tingles
i don't know or yo it just emerges
randomly when you're doing something
else
right you wake up in the middle of the
night and the songs in your head
and this is in the thousand plateaus
chapter on the refrain
yeah so we should have maybe maybe
started with this because this is a
great example a song
is not an object a song is not a thing a
song is a pattern
that repeats so if you think of reality
as a song
instead of a picture and just because i
said that we can
bounce back rhizomatically to
heidegger's essay
the age of the world picture because
heidegger's
more on the side of process philosophy
than substance philosophy he says
the age of the world picture is the age
when we see the world as a picture
only but if you see it as a song like
you said it has this
this emergence this accidentalness
this rep repetition through time
and it's the pattern that creates the
object not the object that creates the
pattern
exactly and a song a simple song
can trigger any kind of memory a breakup
with a girlfriend or a boyfriend
school your friends or something those
summer nights
hanging in the woods drinking beer on
the hood of your camaro
yes so whitehead has this quote that i
like
very simple nature is a process and he
starts off from the very
basic interactions of things which he
actually
gathers up from spidoza and called
something like monads or
data and from these individual
interactions then we get something as
as incredibly complex as human
consciousness
and descartes made the error kogiro ergo
sum
which which supposes that the i exists
before the thinking exists
i think therefore i am which means the i
comes first and that's wrong
it should just be you know
because because of thought i am instead
of
because i think therefore there's yeah
absolutely because when you're
this this idea of of um the self
or even the kojito what is the kojito
but an endless infinite amount of
relations
right like for descartes to say i think
therefore i am
he has to understand the relation
between the chair he's sitting in the
pipe he's smoking
the fire that he's looking at and the
paper that he's writing with
all are interconnected within one event
that is leading up to his meditation
so he doesn't even realize because he's
too
busy compartmentalizing every experience
dividing everything
wiping it away so he can talk about two
substances
mind and body and the bod and actually
the
the meditation is called why the mind is
known better than the body but what he's
really done is
he's gotten rid of all relations the
relations between
the paper the pen the fireplace
the what the clothes he's wearing you
know all of these things that have set
up this event
that that is him writing um
this meditation yeah and the only reason
he can start doing that meditation is
because he already had lunch because if
he was hungry and feeling the pangs of
hunger in his stomach then his body
would be telling him to get his ass out
of his chair
and go eat something instead of
reflecting on how the body
and the mind are connected by the pineal
gland or some
arbitrary distinction that he made or
the or the abstraction of thought
the event the event of thinking itself
the fact that he can remember
specific ideas that he's that he is put
together collected together and now put
them
in a kind of metaphysical argument
so why don't we end by going like way
out to lunch here
and talk about whitehead's panentheism
which is different from pantheism and
that pantheism means
god is everything whereas panentheism
means that god is in everything
as the the
the thing that exists in all
interactions because
obviously for whitehead everything is an
interaction everything is a feeling
which is actually a philosophical term
that he reappropriates from
normal english but all things are
feelings
and he says quote the actual world is a
process
and that process is the becoming of
actual
entities so you don't start with
things but things occasion into each
other
they feel each other just the way like
you hear a song
and that song contributes to
your thought it's not that your thought
exists independently of the world
he calls this prehension right this is
the this is the yeah
that's the uh the state of anticipating
events
but you know i i kind of subscribe to
this kind of pan and theism
because it also leads to whiteheads pan
psychism
which is that all all emergent forms of
matter have mind
but not mind in the sense of
consciousness the sense that they are
related to one another and each
um each uh
even dead matter itself is somehow
affecting or
epi phenomenally affecting some form of
uh entity yeah i don't i don't like
going
to this this realm too much but i mean
what what's actually happening though
is like when you reflect on the entire
history of the universe
just sitting in your chair that is a
an example of that unit of the universe
folding back on itself because the
universe is thinking itself
through your mind and like i said i
don't like
i don't like going there myself it just
seems it just seems spacey but a lot of
people like it
i've heard it i've heard it said and i
think you might be one of those people
i think i'm spacey i think i'm
speechless so why don't you describe for
me that experience of uh
i don't know ego death and uh the world
thinking itself through you
describe it in phenomenological terms
it's not so
i i see this um as a shalinian
so i shelling has this great line where
he says that
spirit is invisible nature nature is
visible spirit they are connected
subject and object are
interconnected and this interconnection
between the real and the ideal the
subject and the object
they are combined as in you know their
identity is like two like your left hand
and your right hand
they're both hands but each of them kind
of reflect
the one and the other um this is how i
see it
i see it in this sense i don't i don't
think the rock
and the ground and everything else is is
has a mind and is you know but i do
think in li
in terms of of de las that what we call
consciousness to any other form of
matter is still a form of expressivity
it's still expressing itself the tree is
expressing itself
by leaning this way by getting light
turning it into simple sugars within
photosynthesis
the grass sheltering other insects
etc the earth having
multiple living organisms intertwined
geological rocks et cetera et cetera et
cetera all of these things
all enmeshed right and you can see it
in a funny way there's this great
example from rave song
about a color red the redness of your
wall is not just one color
there are little tiny degrees of redness
that build up this one
redness of a wall so there's multiple
layers
multiple dimensions that are all
interconnected interrelated
without getting galaxy brain what this
does it it represses that instinct to
make things into abstractions
because if everything is univocal
everything is part of this university
one substance reality then
there's no such thing as representation
that's distinct from that
there's no such thing as abstraction
that's not
already part of nature because that
abstraction
is coming from your mind which is coming
from
you know your evolution and your stomach
gut and
the bacteria that live inside you are
all affecting the way that you're
thinking about stuff so
it's only an illusion that we can
separate
mind from nature in that respect because
our mind is expressing
the what we call it i don't again i
don't want to get too galaxy brained
here but
the fact that you can consider the
events on a star
a million miles away is reflective of
nature
folding onto itself as you brought up
that uh
example previously from delivers but
even even this idea of nature
we tend to see ourselves as homo sapiens
and then there's nature
and right there i categorized us
an animal a living animal and we i
differentiated us from nature
no that's not true that's that's
incorrect we are within nature
we reflect nature as nature reflects us
just like i brought up this example of
the two hands
it's not that we're separated it's that
we're within
and we reflect nature as nature reflects
us
we're a part of this we are a part of
the
the process of nature so it's it's not
just
we divide these two entities there are
multiple entities that make up nature
we're one of those entities yeah and
there's another example i could point to
is
when we when we talk about the laws of
nature it's like
nature exists following these laws but
in this sense
those laws would be part of a substance
metaphysics as if they pre-exist
somehow but from the perspective of
process metaphysics
those laws emerge from all of the
interactions
that nature has with each other whether
they're i don't know electrons or
whatever but those laws emerge they
don't pre-date
you know i this is a really funny memory
of you and i i'm just gonna bring up a
memory
that gives a really good example because
it's not just about organism
it's it's everything um pills and i were
on top of a massive building in toronto
drinking some beers
and ice i looked out me being the
so-called vitalist idealist looked
outside at all these
buildings and roads and cars and
everyone moving around
and i said ah look at this look at this
mashy nation
and he said what do you mean mashy
nation this is process
and i said to him what do you mean he
said well look
each of the roads lead to somewhere
their cars going specific areas
buildings are entered are interconnected
there is life emergent right here
there's cars moving here and there that
are
that are still taking up a specific
space that are still here within time
sounds like i had a bit too much you got
me there pills
all right well why don't we leave it on
that note
good anecdote of a time when i was
unwittingly wise
um thanks for coming back chris and i
hope you guys had some interest
or got your brain percolating in some
area about
uh this stuff i don't we don't actually
get a lot of feedback on this
so i i don't know where it lands all the
time but if you
if you like this or you want us to just
talk about one thinker for an hour we
can definitely do that
on a on an overdose episode
yes if you if you want to hear me
stutter some more
on another podcast uh
for now uh thank you chris thank you for
uh
coming back from the wildernesses of
quebec
i can imagine that must have been a
traumatic experience to return to
your quarantine your quarantined block
in the suburbs so to talk about talk
about um
relations just coming back to
toronto and smelling air the air was
absolutely heavy the air where i was was
so clean and i i mean i sound as you
said
spacey but there really is a difference
there it really
there really is an absolute difference
has it affected your mood too your
your affective your affective uh
carrying of yourself well let me tell
you
um yeah in a weird way yes it did
actually um but you from there you see
you see you know a small town whatever
farmland
farmers everything everything the whole
the whole little little town itself is
interconnected and
everyone knows who and blah blah blah
blah anyways this is this is
nothing to do that we're talking about
no if it has an effect on
your interaction with the world like
your disposition
your prehensions as whitehead would say
towards the world then that would be you
know evidence of this interconnectivity
that is forgotten by cartesian dualism
i just think i just think that um a lot
of people because they keep up their
daily mundane routine
that they're you know their absorbness
as heidegger says their throneness
the the constitution of nazine's you
know kind of absorbness into the world
they miss certain things and and my
favorite poet
who's a kind of you know very big his
name is um
angelus celesius talks about the rose
without no y
the rows without y and it's the rows is
just there
the rows doesn't need a y like we don't
need a y
either everything is is is there and we
we kind of take it for granted
anyways i'm going off here spacey again
well i'm sure that some people would
like to be spacey and
you know being being spacey without
some metaphysical backing makes you kind
of a kook right but if you're gonna
think through it carefully as you have
i'm just saying i'm not gonna put my
effort into that but if you have and you
have what you do
then that's uh an admirable trait and
example to follow
i i think it's weird that we didn't
bring up the three-letter word today we
didn't bring up god at all today
i think that's kind of weird that we
didn't bring we're talking about process
metaphysics
and it didn't come up panentheism
true true true yes the chaos and
pandemicism is god
anyway we'll save that for another time
thank you everyone for listening
goodbye chris thanks for coming by all
right pills thanks a lot
you